this is soba University Hospital one of
the largest in hartum now barely
functioning because of the fighting
between the Sudanese Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces like
many hospitals it's run out of basic
medical supplies
we used to operate two dialysis units
one for adults and another for children
which we had to shut down because of a
lack of supplies the materials necessary
to give dialysis to children aren't
available anywhere in the country
operating rooms are empty staff State
the last procedure was formed on the day
the conflict began the 15th of April
employees are too scared or unable to
come to work
we call on local and international Aid
agencies and charity organizations to
help Sudan and especially sober the
hospital hasn't been damaged by the
conflict but there are no medical
supplies or staff
the only section that's still functional
is the adult dialysis unit but the
violence and the lack of money has kept
many patients away
the road to the hospital is not safe
never mind the cost involved from
transport to Medical fees I'm forced to
spend less money on food for my children
in order to pay for dialysis
the Sudan doctors union says more than
60 percent of the hospitals in Khartoum
have shut down since mid-april
a brief ceasefire enables some medical
assistance to be brought in but the
continuous fighting means they haven't
been distributed to all the hospitals
now that the ceasefire is officially
over people who need help are worried
that even the few functioning hospitals
may not be open for much longer Hiba
Morgan Al Jazeera Khartoum a new
medicine called awesome